good afternoon I'm Beverly wheeler
president of the Alumni Association I'm
pleased to be here today to introduce a
distinguished alumnus who will present
this afternoon's talk mr. Dale Clevenger
considered by international audiences
and colleagues to be the reigning
virtuoso of the horn mister Clevenger is
also consummate and multifaceted
musician long sought after as a teacher
by students are from around the globe
he is increasingly in demand as a
conductor due to his elegance style and
artistry throughout the world he has
performed to acclaim as soloist and/or
conductor in symphonic chamber music and
jazz performances on classical and
commercial recordings three of which won
Grammy Awards and in countless musical
festivals master classes workshops and
instructional engagements among many
highlights of his illustrious career
mr. Clevenger has spent forty five years
with the Chicago Symphony Orchestra he
has been a conductor and her soloist
with numerous orchestras around the
world including recent conducting in
Spain with Daniel Birnbaum as a soloist
he is a member of the faculty of
Roosevelt University and the Jacobs
School of Music at Indiana University in
addition mr. Clevenger received a
Lifetime Achievement Award from the
International horn Society in 2010 and
is the recipient of an honorary degree
Doctorate from Elmhurst College please
join me in welcoming 2011 alumni
distinguished Achievement Award honoree
Dale Clevenger
thank you very much
can you hear me if I'm away from this
mic are nearby this mic okay
yeah you know it would really be nice if
most of you would come closer to the
front this is not a big formal to do
this is it tells me this is a the first
time this has happened in a while so
just lead the way and come closer to the
front and that way I don't have to talk
so loud or so hard or whatever and while
you're walking down I like to know whom
I'm talking to may I see the hands of
all of you who are presently music
students here now
okay thank you very much for coming may
I see the hands of those who are
presently students non-music a few
others a little bit yeah
faculty music or otherwise alumni alumni
all right and administration lots of
those that makes up our audience it's
pretty diverse
I've probably thought about this moment
for longer than you can imagine
what am I going to say you can read in
my CV which you don't have with you so
you may not know very much about me
except what she just said you can read
it there will be one that's a little
more complete I assume but I'm
interested in speaking to each one of
you and knowing what you want to know
about me first of all I should say I'm
very happy to be here this weekend I
walked in the building and started
crying fifty years away from this I have
plenty of Kleenex so I'm okay
and I'm basically a SAP I am quite
emotional I've had lots of things happen
in the last year that have contributed
to that but I lost my wife seven months
ago I got back my son and daughter that
I haven't seen for 12 years six months
ago and you know the the lows and highs
of just my personal life are pretty
pretty amazing and but all of these
highs and lows of one lives one's life
effects everything that you do and
affects who you are and how you think
and so on but this building I said set
right down there was that me i sat right
down there and played three operas one
was Johnny's Kiki and swore Angelica
what you just done recently and then I
played one year we did Hansel and Gretel
and I cannot tell you how many plays
I've seen on this stage which are as
good or better than Broadway they were
then I assume they still are there's no
reason to let that kind of quality go
when you have fantastic drama department
excuse me getting over a cold but I've
written a speech for this occasion a
dozen times I could throw them all out
they did this it never covers the right
thing I'm more interested in what you
want to hear about what I about me what
I have to say I mean there's you know
three dozen subjects which I could name
off like that we could talk about any
one of them for an hour and I only have
less than an hour to do it
so let's I'm going to do the QA right
now if there's time at the end if
there's time at the end because once you
ask the question will store them up and
I'll try to answer those questions when
you walk in the store and you say okay
we're gonna see Clevenger this is the
first time this has happened
you know he was here graduated in 62 not
63 and what was it like then etc etc
what what's on your mind what do you
want to hear me say that's coming
classical French horn repertoire
somebody make a little list a little
list of these things and then and I'll
try to address them as we go
another question that would take seven
books he wants to know what I did with
the Chicago Symphony 44 days 46 years my
dear and I'm you know it's a long time
okay I came my first day was February
the 6 1966 and it's gone by like that
and I can't believe it happened and as I
told the Dennis where are you well just
a few minutes ago you're looking at the
most the luckiest the most fortunate
musician alive there is nobody else who
has been fortunate enough to do what I
have done and and I'm not I say it
humbly and a little bit proud but it the
range of things is I think about and
it's beyond my imagination and it just
came one week at a time one day one
recording one conductor oneness and
pretty soon the years start to go by and
we've been on more than 70 tours 7'o
around the world to New York United
States Europe I can't even count how
many times I've been to Europe
not only with the orchestra but
privately so you you ask an enormous
Liebig question which I will I will try
to cover all right so about the Chicago
Symphony follow your dream get the best
teacher you BA can possibly get and work
your butt off
as actually was here about 15 years ago
conducting and playing a solo it was a
very quick time but you know you you
either go back to a place because you
have a curiosity or you have a reason to
be in town or they have to ask you back
and this is you know the second time
I've been asked I would be happy to come
back quite a bit more often but you know
it takes time and arrangements and so
forth and and I told somebody that the
concert that I conducted either it was
really not very good or it was really
good and it was a bit of a threat to
somebody one of the two is it I don't
the middle ground is not there I I don't
think it was the first you know because
the orchestra played really excellent
excellent for me I played as best I
could but you know they they did you
know I had fun conducting my life has
been an incredible amount of fun
enjoyable try to have fun when you do
when you play or not not very good any
other questions what brought me study
here it's a good question and I will
that'll be one of the first things I'll
touch on
okay
okay I was just telling Dennis that I am
pretty good at imitating conductors
Schulte was like this Claudio Abbado is
like this Piranesi pianissimo I'll do as
much as I can in the time that we have
you see how diverse the questions are
yeah
not much friends many of my classmates
unfortunately have died Nataly osseous
is one of the ones she was actually
ahead of me
two three or three or four years and but
she's one of the few that have kept in
contact and you know that I see coming
back here my roommate Calvin Custer
became a very fine conductor arranger
etc he wrote do you ever remember the
song by Alan Schurman hello muddah hello
father
Here I am at Camp Granada tada tada
my roommate arranged that for him so
there's lots of connections I graduated
in the same graduating class with Rene
Auberjonois and a whole bunch of other
actors who have gone on to Broadway and
movies and so forth you know I'm a
little ahead of Ted Danson but I know he
came out of here also I'll you're making
the list okay anymore yeah
very good question
he came just after I left I came back
and visited when he was you know like
the next year or two after when he was
here and he calls me into his office so
he says tell me about so-and-so you know
a conductor in the band and I had done
something very stupid I talked back to
the conductor and then I didn't
something else very stupid I walked out
of the band and then my section very
stupidly followed me and I said go back
this is not your affair you know but I
talked to Sidney and I have since made
up with that band director I saw him
later on when it is a Richard strange I
saw him in Arizona and when I laid eyes
on him I said Richard please forgive me
I was dumb stupid may I have your
forgiveness I apologize
nothing gone you know I could have been
you know like this and ignored him or
whatever like some musicians do but
that's that's not to get I don't want to
live that way you know I don't have any
almost no people that I don't want to
see any other thing else that's sort of
sort of your question right all right
yeah hard times are with everybody not
just Symphony Orchestra's but you know
I'll try to address the question okay
now we have enough things to to do why
am i why did I come here in the first
place any musician no matter what the
instrument if you want to play
profession
your teacher is everything I I have not
known any horn players of musicians who
actually make it without a good teacher
I suppose there are some but I don't
know them and what you get information
aliy and inspirationally from your
teacher over a course of two three four
six years or whatever is absolutely
paramount to your being at a place I
when I was in high school I was lucky
enough any horn players here yeah
probably the whole class I was lucky
enough when I was 16 to audition and
make the job to play fourth horn in the
Chattanooga Symphony they tell me
there's a little bit of my accent is
still here but you know and of course I
could speak totally without an accent
because I had speech at Carnegie Mellon
University
where they speak excellent speech in the
drama department but the music
department it's not a thing
the lady who sat next to me on third
horn kept talking about Forrest Stanley
who was my teacher here for years and
she was sort of a mentor she helped me
we listened to lots of records together
and she introduced me to music and so
forth and I played two years and Senegal
Symphony which means at least 15 to 20
concerts plus some operas and between my
junior and senior year in high school I
went to Chautauqua studied with Forrest
Stanley for eight weeks and he asked
would you like to come to study with me
full-time I said where he said I teach
it Carnegie Tech our tech our CIT now
it's see him are not CMU but Carnegie
Mellon and I said yes I'd like that he
says I'll try to help you get a
scholarship he got me a very small one
tuition my first year was $800
understand it's grown a little bit since
then but so have salaries grown for the
most part I came here and my life was on
a I was pretty determined to play the
horn professionally I was pretty
determined to play in a top-notch
Orchestra if I could get in I had no
idea where I was on the audition circuit
until after I graduated and started
playing auditions you just don't know
that and four years with him it was
really really really fine the the ballot
you know all of life is a balance
whether you realize it or not and the
good and the bad the high and the low
and love about sad and the happy his
balance was slightly more on the horn
and I also studied
Joseph singer New York Philharmonic his
balance was slightly more on the horn
but a little more on music and I could
do the horn pretty well but I needed to
concentrate on making music by way of
the horn much more and then I met a man
playing in New York when I went to New
York to freelance called Marcy Kahn who
used to teach it at Eastman and played
in the Eastman Rochester Orchestra and
he called me to his house one time and
he said Dale you can do anything on the
horn let's talk about music and I
thought ok and we started talking about
phrasing and tone and beauty and lovely
things all right brain stuff no
mechanical stuff that was pretty well
under undertow and I realized that this
was the beginning of a yet another
journey of thinking more and more and
more about music about the art form
when I get master classes I assume all
of you gonna play tomorrow some of you
what what we do on our instruments no
matter what the instrument is is both
technical and musical it is left brain
and right brain and how you how you
balance those things is extremely
important the right brain activity well
how you want to sound how you need to
play how you are asked to play the
beauty with which you have this
perfection in your head that dictates
the physical it may work that way and
many other subjects I don't know but I'm
I'm a musician I am NOT a word merchant
although I can be s in front of a crowd
for four hours
if I know whom I'm talking to and what
you wanted to talk about so my balance
of teaching is more on the music and I
demonstrate a lot and I show students I
play like they do then I play like maybe
I would I do not teach in the sense of
being my way or the highway
that's arrogance gone to seed wrong it
is a sense of this is something you need
to be able to do this is something you
should do this is something you're gonna
be asked to do you need to be able to do
it it's not like that you play like me
if you want to play in my section
you got to play pretty much like I do
our better but if you want if you need
to play in London or Germany or whatever
then you need to be adaptable to go to
that situation I have many students all
over the world and some of them go and
they stay in a place and they they learn
to play like is there is in that place
and if your audition of an orchestra in
America you need to go hear the
orchestra need to study with the first
horn player or somebody in there to find
out how they play and this would be true
with nearly any instrument I listen to
thousands of auditions thousands just
listen to 400 clarinet auditions not all
at once four separate times about a
hundred people each one we finally have
a new principal clarinetist Chicago
Symphony who took over from Larry combs
and not directly but and he's phenomenal
he's wonderful
he's wonderful to play with and he's a
wonderful guy and the excellence that we
had for so long with Larry is is
continued but how you could easily say
how do you listen to a cello audition or
a bass audition or timpani audition or
English horn or violin
how can you listen to those if you're
not that player my criteria is I listen
do I hear first the music
the artform the beauty the loveliness
our do I hear first the instrument if
it's the instrument I pick up my card
and put no that's it it's very easy for
8090 percent if people play primarily
their instrument if they play so
beautifully that that that my heart is
warmed that I take a deep breath
but it's head-turning you take it you
know you're taken aback by the absolute
loveliness this is the way the great
artists play and sing and if you see if
you hear that first then these are the
people we want to consider and then we
listen further we listen to more and
more pieces we compare their lot at the
top usually it's only it's less than 5%
of all those who audition who actually
will make it to the finals that's how we
keep and I'm sure that's the same thing
and if it's for anybody in the
Pittsburgh work store here now nobody
goodness day oh yeah is that Ron he is
son of a gun I've seen him and I don't
know how long your hair is almost as
wide as mine he used to look at me like
this
and I found out pretty quickly that he
wasn't really questioning what I said
that's just you know usually that was
his way of thinking about what I said am
i right close all right this thing keeps
popping because I probably too loud
anyway I came here to study with Forrest
Stanley I did not apply to another
school at all never even thought of it
and if I hadn't gotten in grade wise I
don't know what I would have done I
would have gone to another school but I
was lucky from the time I was about 14 I
was pretty single-minded about what I
wanted to do not many people are that
way these days my son Jesse youngest son
is very similar he's a junior at Indiana
University and he has got it he's got
all that he plays horn he's got goods
and he has a great possibility of
playing in a major Orchestra and and
right now he's particularly working on
low horn trying to develop his the the
basis of the horn section at the bottom
but as far as getting into an orchestra
and playing there if the secret were
known folks everybody in orchestras most
of us would play music would make music
if we didn't get paid at all I mean we'd
have to do something else but we would
get together in groups which that's how
much we love music if you don't love
music don't get into the music business
do something else my teacher used to say
if you can't be a musician be the best
shoe salesmen are the best something and
and I mean the point there is that
having the highest standards for
whatever you decide to do what you need
to do is be happy to go after as I said
before go after your dream and you keep
trying until you either get it or you
find out that you can't get it
just as simple as that you're looking at
somebody I told you I'm the luckiest
musician alive did I ever have any
failures yeah when you don't pass an
audition you fail an audition you can
say oh I played really well they just
didn't like me you know did you get the
job
nope you failed I got fired from Radio
City Music Hall because I couldn't keep
my mouth shut
I learned extremely valuable lesson keep
your mouth shut do your job don't do
what everybody else does
make fun of the conductor who is quite
possibly the worst I ever played for but
that doesn't prove anything
I didn't didn't keep the job in
actuality is the best thing that ever
happened to me
it's not only that I learned valuable
lesson but I got out of a situation
which was incredibly difficult how can a
human being play a show at nine o'clock
12 o'clock 3 o'clock 6 o'clock in 9
o'clock week after week after week
of course don't do that now because they
don't have they only have periodical
shows but what do you do for 2 hours
while you're waiting for the next show
that's the question so I got out of
Radio City Music Hall and I was lucky
enough to get asked to do Broadway play
I opened the Broadway play Oliver which
is still going all over the world Lionel
Bart who wrote the music couldn't read
music he would sing the melodies to
somebody and they would write them down
he couldn't play the piano I don't know
how he got it done I really don't I
played the the last few shows of a funny
thing happened on the way to the forum
with Zero Mostel
I played the last few shows as a
substitute of
fiddler with Zero Mostel and in several
other shows which didn't last and so on
and I realized that playing shows is not
what I want to do that I want to do the
same thing every day day in and day out
it takes an incredible mindset to do
that but it's not the reason I studied
the horn so I kept taking auditions
other failures I flunked at least 10
auditions didn't make them some of them
I thought I played very well some of
them they told me I played very well at
the Met they said you played the best
audition on horn we've ever heard I said
well why do you didn't die in your homee
because you're an unknown quantity we
don't know what you will do in the Opera
and I was 23 at the time so they took
back somebody who had played at the Met
that they knew and it left an opening in
Chicago and I went on an audition twice
didn't make it the first time and then I
went back again and I was lucky played a
good enough audition and they they they
took me a former conductor or the
Pittsburgh Symphony Andre Previn was
conducting the rehearsal that I actually
played on the last part of my audition
Tchaikovsky fifth symphony things just
happened to fall in line but in New York
when I was freelancing there were months
on end there's no calls no nothing no
money coming in nothing I you know I
called a friend I want Blair friend Isis
what's going on it's just nobody's
working this is nothing happening right
now so will there be orchestras there
will always be orchestras
will there be audiences to go hopefully
if we train young people to like to love
some funny music and generally the young
people who come to concerts to our
concerts and hear it for the first time
they are
absolutely amazed to hear this
production live and they come back and
they want to come back and we do
everything we can to try to help them
get in the lower ticket prices etc etc
but the public the public and
corporations and business and
governments need to support the Arts
they need to do that unfortunately our
politicians haven't gotten that message
they're farmers they don't know anything
about symphonic music nor do they care
they don't anything about the arts the
arts as to President Kennedy said
culture that's culture for our country
do you know how much percentage of every
euro is spent in Austria for the Arts
they could guess I wish it were that
much but it's not it's seven but you
think about it they're not gonna let the
arts go they're not gonna let their
opera house go they pay whatever it
costs and it's expensive
7% out of every euro in Austria goes to
the arts you imagine what would happen
if we did that you know folks one day in
Afghanistan and Iran one day of money
would pay for the Arts in this country
for 20 years all of the Arts handsomely
one day that's where our priorities are
but you got to keep your priorities if
you want to be an artist and a musician
you have to go for it you have to do
whatever you can to make sure people are
getting the message and are hearing it
because art and music changes lives one
of the most profound statements I've
just heard recently music pays dividends
music pays interest
to the listener and to the performer Oh
big time
the the money spent for a young person
spending studying music is paid for
every dollar spent seven to ten comes
back in what profession do you not need
organizational skills in what profession
do you not need discipline you learn all
that studying music whether you'd go on
to be a professional or not and not ten
years in the music but one year two
years and not just an instrument but
voice in classes it's extremely
important big-time music pays interest
what subjects have not covered
okay all right
the subject matter when talking on any
instrument but particularly we were here
today because of the horn the reason I'm
standing up here today it's because of
this instrument we could call it a
catalyst we could call it the
protagonist we could call it the culprit
but it's what I saw at a distance and I
liked what I saw and the more I liked I
saw it I heard it and I love the sound
of it it's magical
pure magic it is a tie it is obviously
made of brass metal but we play with
strings we play with woodwinds we play
with the brass sometimes extremely soft
and we don't often get credit for the
soft playing that we do we often get
credit for the for the big brass stuff
okay I get that but you need to hear the
soft things too and because I love music
studied piano when I was seven and I
started trumpet when I was 11 didn't
want to play the trumpet my daddy
wouldn't buy a horn it's too expensive
so when I was 13 I actually got a school
horn and played it for a while then they
saw that I that I was serious and I'm in
business and gradually he would fork out
the money to buy a horn and you know
very soon I had to make a choice of
where to go to study you know after
playing in the Chattanooga Symphony and
and had a fantastic music department in
my high school orchestra fine orchestra
excellent band excellent marching band
we were like number one in eight states
and sawed another whole subject I didn't
care it I didn't carry this on the field
I cared
Alto cornet but it all is a part of the
learning process and my band director
tried his darndest to talk me out of
being being a professional musician his
experience with the professional music
was chatting in a symphony 8 concerts a
year three operas a year can't make a
living on that he's right
somebody has to do you have to do
something else but it's not
that's nothing Jenny was not yell was
not the only place there were other
places like Boston New York and Chicago
in Philadelphia and so on and I had my
eye and my sights set higher up and I
would have been terribly unhappy had I
not gone for it if I hadn't made it I
would have at least tried so and there
are roughly 2,500 orchestras in America
about 30 to 40 whether you can actually
make a living playing careful the last
three notes that's a very famous piece
telling their Spiegel but there will
always be orchestras they may go they
may wait work less they may make have to
make less money it depends on what the
people behind it are willing to support
it and it's it's been this way since
Bach Hyden and Mozart had a tough time
earning money to do what they do to put
on the productions and right it's been
this way forever the world is just
wouldn't you know they want to see
baseball and football more than they
want to see an opera but when they see
an opera the symphony concert sometimes
it can change their lives so
here's the culprit I could name as I did
here tomorrow morning I will do it in a
master class I'll ask them to name all
the subjects they can think of that they
have to be concerned with on the horn
rhythm intonation articulation beautiful
sound lovely phrasing dynamic contrast
style how to study
Mozart concertos and and and so on and
the list is endless
each name on this list I call it a it's
a compartment so we compartmentalize it
and we can take one day this subject and
talk about it and and expand it and then
we might have to put it back into
context because to talk only about
really about rhythm it's not right it
has to be in the contest of of
everything else as I said there's got to
be a balance and we're constantly
balancing all of these things so let me
give you an example of some different
tone qualities now if you've got a
reasonable here you would choose number
three as being you know if I asked the
question which do you like the most
three why do you like it because it's
the prettiest the others you know I can
tell you why the others are not good but
sometimes students if they do the others
they don't know why they don't know they
don't understand and I have to try to be
as a teacher I have to be a problem
solver my teacher here was a very good
problem solver
he helped me in those there are many
very famous teachers who cannot teach
against the props solve problems they
just tell it to student go home and
practice that doesn't work is they don't
know what to practice or how to practice
what to do to change things only a very
very small percentage of those people
will ever make make it or rise above it
because they to be able to teach
themselves and fix fix their own
problems most people don't know what
problems they have so that's those are
difference at least three different tone
qualities there are as many as five to
ten different tone qualities we have to
have to play depending on the volume if
I play for you
what's at the beginning of Chuck asking
for well therefore horns playing we do
fit 5 v 1 player plays the low part
they're actually soon's playing at the
same time and nobody ever hears them
because the horns overshadow them and
that's an example of the robust strong
playing a conductor may have an idea
about whether or not' is shorter or
longer or whatever but when I play my
section is obliged to follow to the best
of their ability but there are soft
things too
the beginning of super 9 anybody have an
idea of how many pieces start out with
the horn a couple of dozen boom horn is
the first thing are it's the first day
after the strings go like this ticket
you get to get to get to get to get up
boom and we have to have the presence of
mind the the knowledge of what to do and
how to do it and an idea of musically
what what should take place and what
should happen and then trying to follow
our own conscience and whatever the
conductor might say and you know if
they're doing like this or whatever are
they flinch or if they make a face if I
do something wrong that conductor and I
have a chat because you know until I
know how he plays the horn he or she
plays the horn or another instrument in
the orchestra context they are not
allowed to make faces you know because
they are nothing without us absolutely
nothing if they are really good and they
know their stuff they can be inspiring
and helpful and make us play way beyond
what we can imagine but you know our
respect goes up for those conductors who
have played in an orchestra and in a
good Orchestra and a lot of people have
it so loud and soft there's the there's
different articulations that we have to
think about
etc we have to play in three and a half
to four different octave ranges today
I'm not getting it
I don't another day I might get it but I
don't usually play down that low it's
below my salary that's four octaves
now do I ever have to play up there oh
and a rare rare times would I do it on
this horn no our this mouthpiece no and
that's a whole other subject is what
equipment I have double I just had lunch
with Bill Caballero and he was telling
me about what he plays for high horn
stuff and so we have to plan ahead
according to what we're going to play
and what we're not going to play and how
we've got to go out loudly got to play
etc etc at this point in my career I
have done it's only about one piece that
would really love to play you would
never guess but it's fantastic I'd love
to play complete opera of Rosenkavalier
I played the sweet many many times
different sweets but it's incredible
they're gonna do it at IU in next
semester and if my son gets to be one of
the first horn players I told him I'll
come down and assist you
just to play through the Opera but I can
be more choosy about what I play what I
don't play and because of my situation
with my wife I lost my wife I think I've
told you seven months ago to breast
cancer she was my assistant for 25 years
whenever we had extra horns and it's as
mu T says Dale you're in a storm still
and you don't need to be a hero in the
storm so take it easy don't don't feel
like you have to play all the major big
stuff all the time and so I'm diverting
some of that now to my associate and yes
it hurts my ego not to be able to do
that because I want to go out there and
do it I because in my mind I'm 27 years
old but the body says otherwise and I
have to pretty soon I have to see which
rules my life my ego are my reason and
ultimately the reason has to do it it's
got to be there so I have about seven
more minutes is there something you'd
like me to say or talk about yes ma'am
it's like any other orchestra they're a
fantastic orchestra and and Jimmy Levine
is a fantastic musician who hasn't taken
care of his body all his life and now
he's paying for it you know if you don't
exercise and you overeat and you have
physical problems and and so on I don't
care who you are you're gonna pay for
that but playing many different or
conductors coming in some of them know
what they're doing and some of them
don't know what they're doing and most
of the time we play better than the
conductor conducts and they find that
out pretty quick because they get a
better product than they're expecting
and they don't have much to say and when
they do talk they better say something
worthwhile and it's the same at the Met
same in Pittsburgh same in Chicago not
not any different whether it's an opera
performance or Symphony performance yeah
well I made a DVD with Barenboim and
Itzhak Perlman
probably one of the most high pinnacles
of my life that project playing that
with him it was amazing just amazing and
I could go on and on a long time but
it's it's a great piece obviously it's
the showpiece for horn and they're
phenomenal musicians going into the
project I had played it many more times
than both of them coming out of the
project I learned so much about playing
Brahms from Barren boy it's just you
know I am continually amazed and humbled
and how much I don't know what can I say
but I am still a student I am still
learning I'm not gonna stop learning
even when I put this down officially and
commercially and whatever I'm still
gonna be learning I learned more from
students than they have any idea that
that that that they have taught me you
know I don't always tell them that they
they did but so that's a it's a long
subject anything else that I didn't yeah
living composers I really like playing
John Williams music it's not great in
the sense of Bach Beethoven Mozart but
it's really fun to play I know him
personally I know you know he when he
wrote me the horn concerto I said John
write me some of the stuff like you play
in it like he wrote in the movies he
says Dale I write movie music for
eight-year-olds now that's honest and to
him it may be true but his musics gonna
be around a long time and where he's
working on right now a piece called
a movie called Lincoln it's about
Abraham Lincoln with Spielberg and
Chicago Symphony is gonna do the
soundtrack next May and I look forward
to that he stopped Midway in August to
write another piece and on this I would
probably finish this chat he stopped to
write and he sent it to me and I got it
after we got back from the tour in the
mid-september
serenade for horn and strings for Alice
Clevenger John Williams I can't even say
it without tearing I started it hit me
like a ton of bricks and I was on the
floor literally crying because I know
what he did he used to have Thanksgiving
it
house many times and he stopped his
schedule and wrote a piece for my wife
tells the kind of person he is
it's it's just amazing fantastic are
there other composers yes that I that
are really really good I like John John
Corigliano and so on there's a composer
who graduated just ahead of me here
gamers named second lives in Boston but
he writes really good stuff I think of
it maybe after the think it's over but
you have been a very attentive audience
and I hope you know a little bit more
about me as I said I'm an emotional SAP
at times sometimes when I'm playing I
can be like that and very determined
and at other times you know music moves
me I love it I think it's the greatest
thing it's the greatest decision I've
ever made is to be a musician and if I
weren't a musician I'd be listening to
music and never forget that music pays
interest dividends thank you